now the kids are in class it's time to
get enough school staff tonight there is
a need for bus drivers and sub teachers
employees who have a commercial driver's
license but do a different job of the
district are able to fill in in those
bus driver spots 8 news now reporter
sally jaramillo joining us live now with
some reaction from parents and teachers
on filling these positions
i spoke to parents and teachers about
these shortages they say it is a
continuing issue and they hope that this
year it gets resolved
our first day of school we went to the
bus at 704 like we were supposed to and
by 8 o'clock the bus still had not shown
up the first day back for karina
singer's daughter didn't start so well
she ended up driving her and a few
friends to school but it's been
happening since kindergarten and
it's extremely frustrating especially
for parents working early relying on
school buses so i think that
you know even with the subs too it's
been an issue for a long time i think
that they need to vet these people
better and probably pay them a higher
wage so that they can get better people
christian nigro teaches kindergarten at
steve short elementary and has seen how
tough it is to get a sub to cover you
know the sub issue is one of these
things that's literally the bane of my
existence like uh it is very
very difficult when trying to take time
away uh for example i actually have to
take off four days this coming september
my mother passed away niger is concerned
due to the shortage of licensed
educators tutors are specifically to
help the kids that need a little extra
help
and instead they're getting pulled in
all different directions to go and fill
in substitute positions because we can't
get the subs and so we're finding that
we have to move the counselor into a
classroom pcsd you need to do better
we're putting our kids in your hands we
don't take them to a doctor without
thoroughly vetting them parents and
teachers hope to see change sooner
rather than later really go through
these applications and get these
substitute teachers in because this is
so unfair for not only the students but
the employees
i reached out to ccsd about these
shortages and in a statement in part
they tell me
ccsd has more than four thousand
teachers in its
substitute teacher pool and currently
has 239 bus driver
vacancy ccsd hires year-round for all
available positions and offers paid
training for those interested in
obtaining their commercial driver's
license they also say they are working
hard to staff more than 1 500 routes for
now reporting live sally jaramillo 8
news now